اهلا وسهلا فيكم في البيت السعودي انا
السونه ونورتونا واتمنى انكم تنبسطوا هنا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
معكم عبد الرحمن الخياط انا سايت مانجر
[موسيقى]
الكاس العالم موجود في قطر
عن شويه عن التقافه السعوديه وطبعا ورائي
موجود منطقه الفالكونجيا اللي بتشرح فيها
المنتخب
[موسيقى]
طبعا المنتخب المفضل عندي يقول لي بسجله
اكيد اللي هو السعوديه بحكم انه سعودي
لاعب المفضل كريستيانو رونالدو الدون ما
حد يقدر ينكر الموضوع ده توقع اللي فوز
بصراحه المجموعات جدا صعبه الفرق جدا صعبه
بس توقع بيكون
البرازيل
[موسيقى]
طبعا الصعوبات اللي وجعناها طبعا كلنا
عارفين الوقت يعني عندنا نقدر نقول ثلاثه
اسابيع عشان نبني البيت السعودي بكل اللي
موجوده فيها بكل العاب بالمسرح هذا كله
اتخذ معنا ثلاثه اسابيع بالضبط
في وقتنا في قطر وغير كده كاس العالم
وصعوبه كاس العالم وحجمه وهذه الاشياء
بتسبب ضغط نفسي انك تنتج المشروع
طبعا كاس العالم يعني للكثير بحكم حبي
للكوره كره القدم وكره القدم وحروفه في
السعوديه هي الرياضه الاولى
وحبنا لنا فيها ما عمر راح تغير لانه كاس
العالم بجمع العالم كلها مع بعض زي ما
احنا شايفين في قطر بتلاقي الارجنتيني
بتلاقي البرازيلي بتلاقي الاوروبي من جميع
انحاء العالم كلها المستمعين مبسوطين
بنضحك مع بعض
نتفرج المباراه
[موسيقى]
بين النشيد الوطني
للكبار كمان الله يعطيكم العافيه
واهلا وسهلا فيكم
رحيلنا فيصل العنزي جاي لنا للبيت السعودي
جميل جدا تعبانين على التعليقات الموجوده
فئات الجميع فئات الاعمار الموجوده للصغار
كبار
وكانت جدا مناسبه يعني صراحه اجواء تفاصيل
مهما تكلمت ما راح اوصف يعني ولو جزء بسيط
نشكر كل القائمين عليه
وعلى الغائبين ايفون في الاتحاد السعودي
على كل ما وفروا لنا من راحه
تنظيم اجمل من رائع جدا جبار والحقيقه
مستمتعين بكل لحظه في المنتديات الحمد لله
شكرا والله كاس العالم
في دوله عربيه مثل قطر وفعلا قطر قطر
بالعالم ان قد قدها
وصوت بنيه تحثيه ما شاء الله
عظيمه ما شاء الله
فعاليات في كل مكان
واحد جمهور كله حاضر
ان شاء الله نقدم
الكره السعوديه